>> Shane: TAKE A LOOK AT THE
KEYS TO THE GAME.  TTING A STIC
MYERS DROPPED IT, THAT MILLER I
MAKES A
THE THIRD TIME IS  STICK BUT IT
RIGHT BACK TO JACK   HE
THOU
RONDBJERG AND  NICK LETTING
KEEGAN KOLESAR .
ON THE DOORSTEP
COMES DOWN.
BO HORVAT SCORE
ON THE FOLLOW-UP AND THE INSON
OFF THE SKATE LOUD WITH A WRIST
BLOCKED AWAY BY COME DOWN, A LI
MARCHESSAULT FINDS THE OPEN AREA
THE BEST IS THROUGH
CENTER ICE WITH JONATHAN
MARCHESSAULT.
LOST IT, GETS IT, WHITECLOUD
ACROSS, MARTIN IS OPEN
CURLS UP THE BOARDS.
.
A LITTLE STUTTER STEP AND
SCORES.
TAYLOR PEARSON SET BACKHAND PAS
A GREAT PLAY AS MILLER IS GOING
TO DRIVE PIETRANGELO BACK WHICH
OPENS  BIG SAVE BY ROBIN
LEAWAY BY BREAKAWAYS IN THE LAS
THREE GAMES.DORE.
MILLER REVERSES THE FIELD,
YOU CAN SEE THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS,
MARTINEZ TURNS IT OVER AND
PETTERSSON
COMING BUT A GREAT PLAY IN FRONT
>> Shane: VANCOUVER HAS REALLYLY
THE POWER DRIVE HERE FROM HUNT,
KICKED OUT BY
DEMKO  THIS
STAGE OF THEIR SEASON.PLAYS IT
TOP FOR THEODORE AND AROUND CHA
THE ONE TIMER BLOCKED WIDE BY
MYERS.
FIRST PENALTIES OUT OF THE